hello Conan O'Brien here and I'm in
downtown Los Angeles in the fashion
district because I want to try this
brand new fad that's sweeping the nation
it's called an escape room basically you
get a bunch of your friends you go into
a room you're locked inside there were
clues and puzzles and you all have to
work together to figure your way out of
the room I wanted to bring my friends
and try it unfortunately they were all
busy so I brought my producer Jordan
Lansky hey Jordan you want to help me
you think we can get work together and
get out of the escape room my mind there
take sunglasses off please
I took my whipped mind off dramatically
can you whip mop dramatically a little
motto rip them off dramatically that's
not them
no like this put them on now whip them
off hopeless that's good if you can't
get your glasses off how we gonna get on
the escape this is exciting we've just
met Stephanie is that right hey
Stephanie nice to meet you
what's the fastest time that a group has
gotten out of this room 47 minutes I
think we will beat that record in
general are you good at solving riddles
and puzzles I think with my powers of
observation and deduction in combination
with your proclivity for academics will
be strong team
okay he's sort of the Spock to my curve
yeah
each room has a different theme which
room you gonna put us in I'm putting you
in the detective and what era is this in
1940 1940s how common is it for people
who are about to play the game to dress
in period clothing
[Applause]
you want to try and accent you anything
I believe in the 1940s people spoke much
as they do now what you're mentioning
was immediate effect ation okay he takes
the fun out of anything this looks like
a real 1940s detectives office and who
is this right here
that's the secretary this is the
secretary yeah Wow
at this moment she's doing more than my
assistant ever does her name's Sona she
just kind of she watches The Bachelor a
lot at her desk all right so I'm gonna
set this timer for one hour
have fun and I guess you're gonna get
out in 46 minutes good morning gentlemen
I'm the detective secretary said to give
this to you and that's very important so
you finally made it
I had to visit it the other day from an
old friend an old blonde friend this
Dame hasn't changed a bit she still as
cold as a July in Frisco
this guy's not funny help me as I figure
out which of those gangsters goons is
behind the jewel thefts that's the first
thing we have to do you're wasting time
I read this thing three times the right
of Liberty lost about 20% of our time we
need to be somewhere quickly in survey
room there are many objects here it's
visually stimulating and very complex I
think we need to break this down and
understand what lies ahead of us three
two three two this will get you started
this puzzle it says three two three two
at the top so I'm gonna circle every
third winning a circle every second I've
left something go ahead under under skip
ahead under is the under my pie plate
watch out first This Is It this is the
first key what's this guy does not wear
the smallest shoes this key opened up
this drawer suspects here we go Susu so
the guy with the shoe size 11 is either
peanuts Romanello or is from Hollywood
the guy from Boyle Heights is six feet
tall
Johnny Tomatoes is not from Allah
would and neither is the guy who is 6 1
wasn't this guy he's a crappy detective
back in 11 is either peanuts Romanello
or from Hollywood right if this guy from
the size 13 shoes is the guy from
Hollywood then that would stand to
reason that size 11 is peanuts Romanello
this is hard this is really hard is your
way to order include you can use the
phone over there that's right I got my
partner working on the case he's solving
the clues Wow dolly and I are having a
real sweet time together she is one
tomato you know what I'm saying
yes yes she's got an eye piercing that
doesn't go along with the 1940s do you
think that would get her fired
working in a period costume but
apparently they don't care about that
kind of thing he says he wears the
smallest shoe therefore it stands to
reason he's not the shortest guy and we
know that was not Mickey Siegel
oh that's just air conditioning okay
half of the time has elapsed what
percentage of the tasks have we
completed about five percent I just
solved one major problem right here
check this out now you have ten minutes
left
I've been trying to decipher this Morse
code they're broadcasting but can't get
very far both of you need to be working
on that right now all assemble the crime
scene photo you do that recede with this
I'm gonna start chewing gum we need to
work in a linear fashion to uh saying
yes on who the jewel thief is and you
have to tell us if we're right who do
you think it is Mickey C is it Siegel
[Music]
Dame
I'm getting pretty hot and bothered see
witty dances see I need to know who the
true thief is see and I think you know
see you're not allowed to damage
anything in here oh I'm sorry I
apologize so I have a coin
look there's 300 clams here 1940s I
could buy you a Buick what can you tell
us I'm serious this is yours this is
real money this paint is [ __ ] okay
just a little bit of help here
can you just stuff this down there and
after they get in the movies that box
over there looks important though but
that's only for one of the four numbers
why do you get physical there are steps
to take the next step falling apart the
scenes playing the part then the one
here that really knows what he's doing
maintain your focus airplane this is a
mechanical device it won't reason with
logic you're a mechanical device and you
don't reason with logic I ornate it in
the file cabinet over there that's a
nice clue I left for the next guy
good what if you move that picture over
there it's crooked look at this
anything on that scene it says it says
where I've seen that before
where was the theater you know things
down you don't keep track of it I put
things down and I don't know where they
are or maintain focus you're costing us
valuable it's just another puzzle
another okay quick update here's we are
a Gordon did a really good job he found
out that one of the combinations is ste
al I are my part just realized that if I
throw my belt over the top of that pipe
I can probably hang myself this [ __ ]
is open so we're making progress
ah success keys this might be the final
step yeah we did
[Applause]
our thanks to everyone who helped us in
the escape room wonderful but I men I
that wasn't for me
you